hi guys it's Lucy Hale and today I am
doing the wired autocomplete interview
so you want me to Vanna White it just
like ok what does Lucy Hale do well I
ask myself that every day Lucy Hale is
an actor a singer fellow human I've been
acting oh gosh
supporting myself since I was 15 but
kind of my whole life it's kind of all I
know alright who is Lucy Hales it's
gonna say boyfriend boyfriend best
friend oh god I have a few of them I
have my best for a nanny I have a best
friend Kristen I have a best friend
Kelsey I have a best friend Janelle
they're all sitting behind the camera
right now so that's why I'm saying that
because I don't want to leave anyone out
but I think probably Annie is who most
people would assume because she's an
omni Instagram photos with me who is
Lucy Hale related to people always ask
me if I'm related to Andi Hale he was on
Gilligan's Island Alan Hale and Dee Hale
who is that I'm related to no one in the
entertainment business I'm the only
person in my family who does what I do
who is Lucy Hale how I Met Your Mother
so I was on How I Met Your Mother twice
once when I was 18 and then they brought
me back for I believe it was the finale
episode and I played oh gosh she had a
name and slipping my memory
what's Robin's little sister's name
Katie will have to IMDB it but I'm
pretty sure it's Katie and she was
Canadian and like talkie and that's all
I really remember but it was a blast I
love that show and I loved all those
people all right when is Lucy Hales
birthday Lucy Hales birthday is June
14th 1989 ripe old age of 30 I just know
I'm a Gemini to a tee no it's dramatic
okay sir is Lucy Hale a singer I like to
think I'm a singer I actually started
doing started out singing when I was
younger and that kind of led to the
acting and then I did an album a couple
years ago and now I kind of do music
through like acting projects and I sing
in the shower and on the 405 I mean I
think it sounds good
that might be arguable I don't know is
Lucy Hale a vegetarian I don't know
maybe I like to call myself a social
carnivore because I never eat meat like
alone I never have it a lot but when I'm
out with friends I'll occasionally have
it is Lucy Hale in Riverdale I'm in a
Riverdale spinoff
I play Cady Keane they took Josie from
Josie the Pussycats and followed her to
New York and it's like five years in the
future it really doesn't have much to do
with Riverdale other than the fact that
Josie's in the show Riverdale is very
suspenseful and mysterious and dark and
Cady Keane is a very inspirational show
and it's about dreamers and I play an
aspiring designer but we do have some
familiar Riverdale faces on the show I'm
in one episode of Riverdale I can't say
that I'm part of the Riverdale cast but
I was in one of the most recent episodes
is Lucy Hale related to Alan Hale jr.
yes I'm just kidding no I'm not but I
might be related to Andy Hale is Lucy
Hale single very very very single but
not sad but single all right here we go
what is Lucy Hales middle name so my
full name is Karen Lucille Hale people
always think I'm lying I'm not lying
karen was a grandmother Lucille was a
great-grandmother I think it's like a
southern thing my mom was trying to keep
all the women and the family happy
but I've always gone by Lucy ever since
I was born but you can call me Lucille
if you want
what does Lucy Hale tattoo say well I've
got 13 of them so this one says love her
but leave her wild there's one here that
says oh god what does it say courage to
your heart it's been a while there's a
Bible verse on this side and then I have
like an evil eye a moon a Sun Gemini
constellation elephant a bow an a the a
is the Pretty Little Liars when all the
girls went and got our character initial
on our shush finger my favorite ones it
actually hurt the most this one hurt the
most because it's right on the bone I
think that's it it's kind of sad if you
don't remember all of your tattoos what
color are Lucy Hales eyes my eyes are
hazel sometimes more on the green side
I'm gonna say they're hazel what is Lucy
Hales favorite color this is a great
question favorite color to wear black
favorite color in life lavender
what is Lucy Hales email address that's
just never in a million years gonna
happen Lucy Hale one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten at gmail.com
distance yells email address probably is
somewhere on the Internet is Lucy Hale
hosting New Year's Eve I did the last
four years I hope to continue that
tradition for three years I was the New
Year's rockin Eve correspondent in New
Orleans and then they moved me up to New
York this last year and it was really
fun really amazing very scary there were
a lot of people there and live TV is
unpredictable but it's a good thing cuz
Lucy Hale related to Selena Gomez I am
we're actually twins and we don't like
to talk about it a lot in public no oh
you know what when I was younger I used
to get that I looked like her all the
time I have met Selena because I did
Wizards of Waverly Place when I was like
17 or 18 my long-term boyfriend at the
time played her brother on Wizards of
Waverly Place so I would see her all the
time
it's Lucy Hale related to Tony Hale
maybe no I'm not moving on is Lucy Hale
Australian what
welcome to the Shari that's pretty good
welcome to the Shari that's all I know I
only know how to how to do that
consonant I'm not Australian I've been
to Australia once I love it I kind of
wish I was Australian is Lucy Hale dead
I'm here to break it to you that I'm not
dead I'm still here still kickin it
can't get rid of me that easy all right
how is how is Lucy Hale oh is Lucy Hale
you know what I'm so glad that you asked
I'm great I'm actually great really
happy I've been spending time in New
York I'm back in LA I have no complaints
thank you thank you so much how many
people stop and ask me that how did Lucy
Hale and Ashley Benson meet
is actually a great oh sorry that says
how did Lucy Hill and Ashley Benson met
so we met actually on MySpace I was 15
we had mutual friends in common I didn't
like randomly find her kendall schmidt
who was on Big Time Rush this like
nickelodeon show he was kind of the
linking factor I saw that he was friends
with her and we kind of became friends
through him he thought we would get
along and he was right but we became
like MySpace friends and then our first
hangout was at Disneyland and we were
like super super tight when we were
teenagers and then kind of lost touch
and then Pretty Little Liars brought us
back together but we met on MySpace it's
really weird actually
how does Lucy oh sorry only not that
good at this okay there we go how does
Lucy Hale stay in shape I am actually
one of those people I really enjoy
working out I love getting up at 6:00
a.m. in the morning and I just get it
out of the way and it just makes me feel
better about life in general what else
do I like to do hike I'm a great trainer
named Adam I don't know I like to switch
it up how to get Lucy Hale hair how to
get Lucy Hale hair how I get my hair the
way it looks I have no idea because I
never do it when you see me for events
or on camera it's never me doing it it's
always someone else I've tried to
achieve the look I end up burning my
hair off it's just never good I know how
to do a low pony and that's about it I
can put a headband on I did once I was
probably like eight or nine and I've
always had these baby hairs that would
won't grow out past like two inches and
I was like well if I shave them off
they'll never come back well as we know
that if you shave something off it does
grow back and so for like a good couple
of months I had like tiny tiny bangs but
just right here last one where was Lucy
Hale born I was born in Memphis
Tennessee and I lived there until I was
15 somehow convinced my mom to move to
LA with me for a pilot season and I'm
still here but yeah my family's all
still there I love it I love Memphis so
much that I named my dog Elvis how after
Elvis Presley I still say y'all like
when I get like if I get mad else I'll
be like I'm tired tired southern is a
lazier way of speaking because when I'm
to LA I had to lose my accent so I went
to it's called an accent reduction coach
they give you like a diagram like a
diagram of a tongue and where your
tongue should hit your mouth and so I
had to learn to like enunciate and my
ass accent reduction coach told me to
not listen to my mom because she has
like the sweetest most southern lady
ever and so now I did a movie last year
where I had to get a southern accent
back and you would think it'd be easier
but it was actually harder because for
so long I was telling my brain not to
speak this way it's a little sad now I
just have like a neutral accent where
did Lucy Hale grow up half Memphis
Tennessee half LA moved to LA when I was
fifteen I guess ed kind of got the best
of both worlds where did Lucy Hale go to
high school I was home-schooled for high
school I've never stepped foot into a
high school before I did it all I was
the valedictorian of my class it was the
best of everything in my class because
it was a class of one where does Lucy
Hale live like give my full address no I
lived part time LA part time New York
part time Memphis so I feel lucky I'm
like bicoastal and it's very fun and
exciting okay guys I hope you learned a
thing or two about me and thanks for
watching